the Joe Rogan experience do you do
intermittent fasting yeah as much as I
can
one of the other guys that was on this
tour of Israel with me is Valter Longo
and he's the arguably the world's expert
on this what a great name isn't it he's
an Italian guy Volta lungo Longo yeah
like the coffee guy Colin when you got a
real problem yeah yeah well he's uh he's
written a book and he is the probably
world's expert in human periodic fasting
his for everyone who wants to know about
what the best periodic fasting protocol
is there isn't one we don't know yet
we're right on the cusp there haven't
been enough studies but there are a few
types I go through them in my book so
because so we won't have time to go
through all of it but there's the what
is it the 18 18 hours yeah is it going
if you can go skip breakfast have a late
lunch that's a good start that's what I
try to do every day it's not always
possible like when you're in Africa and
they're feeding you massive meals three
times a day but the that's what you
wanted to be hungry for part of the day
or you can go a little more extreme and
skip two days and what's that what's the
benefit of being hungry great question
and this is what my lab and others
figured out in a year - you know the
first few years of the 21st century we
figured out that these genes that extend
lifespan these sirtuin genes are
activated by being hungry in part by
raising nad levels which you we any man
will mimic the effect of so being hungry
actually raises your life span some sort
of war right so caloric restriction is
what we used to talk about a lot if you
restrict the calories of a rat who isn't
actually discovered back in the early
20th century we'll make them live up to
30% longer not in an old state but it
prevents them getting old so the rights
don't get cancer heart disease and all
of these other good things and that was
the only thing that we knew up until
about 20 years ago even ten probably and
so we used to think I'd be had to be
hungry all the time and there was a
still is a society called the calorie
restriction Society
and they were hungry all the time that
very small meals which is pretty tough I
tried that and gave up after a week but
this new paradigm is that you don't have
to always be hungry similar to you don't
always have to be on a treadmill you can
do it for a short time make it intense
and then you can let your body recover
and go back to our normal life for a
little bit and that's great news that
means that we can have the L cake and
eat it too so to speak as long as the
cake doesn't have a lot of sugar in it
now when you are on this protocol of
restricted eating plus metformin when do
you take what and when do you exercise
and how do you balance it out like what
when do you know what to do what oh I
use my body as a guide you know now that
I'm 50 I have a pretty good like you you
know you know how your body feels and
reacts
I'm also measuring it a ring that that
measures my pulse in my sleep is that
the aura yeah yeah I spell that eh oh
you oh you re yep that isn't Kevin Rose
a part of that company is that is that
it yeah okay me says yeah okay from dig
you know dig calm you don't know dig no
I'm how dare you sorry it's a good place
to go find cool [ __ ] okay okay
dig calm shout out to dig yeah I go
there every day because real interesting
stories on the Internet you're always
finding cool weird videos and just
fascinating science stories human nature
human interest stories sounds good
I have a watch what kind of watch you're
using the Apple watch okay how does that
measure by the way they just released an
Apple watch five today Oh apparently
it's better you might want to get it was
it do what is though Apple watch - yeah
how's it well I change your songs and in
my headphones tells the time
occasionally but yeah what's useful with
it is a pulse and activity mmm and if I
haven't moved enough during the day I've
got a standing desk and that's been
helpful to make move around a little bit
more but mainly it's a no seduce
occasional blood test to make sure that
my body's optimized as best I can
personalized and usual is
you read the data off your watch like
how do you read it what what application
are you using nothing special just on my
phone have a look okay so you just have
a look like what your resting heart rate
is how much activity how far you're
walking how many calories you're burning
that kind of deal yeah yeah pretty
simple and I'm happy to say my resting
heart rates really low which means you
know things are going okay so far for me
even though I don't do enough exercise
as you rightly point out I think my
resting heart rates 46
[Applause]